so I think a lot of people thought when
you bought Twitter that this is kind of
an outlier like how does this what
doesn't fit with these other things
you're doing I never thought that
because I think you're dealing with big
civilizational issues and problems and I
was right on your page I think Twitter
is one of them I mean you have talked
about this at woke mind virus yes and
really apocalyptic terms you should
explain why you don't think it's
hyperbole to say things like it's
pushing civilization towards suicide
first of all what is the walkmine virus
and if we don't deal with this nothing
else can get done tell me why you think
that
yeah so
um
I think we need to be very cautious
about anything that is anti-meritocratic
and anything that is uh
that that results in the suppression of
a free speech
so you know those are two other aspects
of the work blind virus that I think are
very dangerous uh is that it's often
anti-mureocratic you can't you can't
question things uh even the questioning
is bad so uh
you know you know another way to
almost Anonymous would we cancel culture
and obviously people have tried to
cancel you many times many times yeah I
mean every week yeah
from left and right I've had it from
both sides yeah and it's interesting
people you and I are both like in that
little group of people maybe it's a
bigger group now yeah who who are called
conservative who haven't really changed
I don't see you think of you as a
conservative definitely
yeah like I I at least think of myself
as a moderate uh you know uh so I mean
uh at least like I've spent a massive
amount of My Life Energy building
sustainable energy uh you know electric
vehicles and and batteries and solar and
stuff uh to help save the environment
that's that's not that's not a
it's not exactly far right no you drew
that diagram